the fda authorizing pfizer's covid19
vaccine for emergency use
clearing the way for millions of doses
to be rolled out within
days i am thrilled to report that the
fda has authorized the fisa vaccine we
have already begun shipping the vaccine
to every state and zip code in the
country
the first vaccine will be administered
in less than 24 hours the pandemic may
have begun in china
but we are ending it right here in
america
here here with new details fox news
medical contributor dr nicole sapphire
nicole welcome
tell us what you think about the speed
of this going out
and also some people are concerned that
the speed might
might be impacting the safety how do you
feel about that
well rachel i don't think most people
understand what an incredible scientific
feat
this has been it is so multi-layered not
only do we have a vaccine using novel
technology
for a disease that has been present less
than a year
and has a 95 efficacy but thanks to
operation warp speed
is ready to be distributed and
administered within 24 to 48 hours of
receiving that fda eua
this is unprecedented and i understand
why people feel that you know they don't
like the term warp speed they feel like
maybe safety corners are being cut
that is not the case the big thing here
the scientific discovery process has not
been tainted whatsoever
what happened was through operation warp
speed they were manufacturing the
vaccine
in parallel while they were still
studying it that usually doesn't happen
because there's a chance that the
vaccine won't be successful
but because operation warp speed put
money into the manufacturing hoping that
it would be successful
that is why we have the vaccine right
now it is not crop it is not cutting
safety corners whatsoever
now that said there are some people in
the name mainly they are pregnant women
that they're saying should not
receive this vaccine why
well rightfully so in clinical trials
there are certain people excluded when
they're studying medications
pregnant people young children those
with severe allergies
are among the top of people who usually
aren't included when you're studying
something new
and so because we don't have data on
them we can't necessarily recommend that
they take it
it's possible that it would be
completely safe in them but we can't
prove it and because we can't prove it
we have to hold off on recommending it
there are studies that are going to be
started in early 2021
for pregnant people and for others
however we don't have the data quite yet
which
you know for those women that are
pregnant or planning to become pregnant
we understand because covet 19 can be
scary for them it is showing to have
some negative consequences so the best
they can do
is just keep themselves safe we know how
to protect ourselves from the virus it's
not only just a vaccine
you can hand wash you cover your mouth
and you socially distance and that's
what they're going to have to do well
doctor you've always been giving us
amazing advice throughout this pandemic
so thanks for joining us this morning
and giving us the latest on that
thanks rachel